il potere dei sogni
quando noi sogniamo
è come se avessimo davanti una tela
bianca e la nostra fase onirica ci
permette di creare immaginare scolpire
qualcosa che prima era assolutamente e
terra dargli una forma
e magari è riuscito anche a plasma
avevano qualcosa di reale molto spesso
oggi quando noi abbiamo
una realtà come quella che circonda che
si imbruttisce ogni tanto ci inorridisce
per quello che riguarda la mia
generazione molto spesso ci toglie
quello che è l'essenza c'è la
possibilità di
immaginarci un futuro
ci ritroviamo un po in questa situazione
in cui rifiutiamo quello che ci viene
attorno l'immaginazione diventa quasi un
rifugio a questo punto per scappare
dalla realtà diventa un po come diceva
jim morrison datemi un sogno in cui
vivere perché la realtà mi sta uccidendo
e e invece poi succede
per fortuna che un'idea un sogno che tu
hai coltivato che credi che condivide
con qualcun altro nasce diventano
solamente un sogno ma diventa un idea
diventa qualcosa di concreto che viene
condiviso da una community in rete
magari e e diventa qualcos'altro di
vento movimento diventa qualcosa di
tangibile
nel 2012
ho iniziato come attivista
un attività di diffusione del progetto
di open source ecology open source
ecology un movimento internazionale di
ingegneri ai produttori attivisti il cui
obiettivo è quello di creare
una nuova forma di ecologia con
l'utilizzo di tecnologie
come voi sapete è l'open source è un
movimento è una procedura per la quale i
progetti sono condivisi in rete e le
persone possono accedere liberamente con
questo approccio
open source ecology ha iniziato a
diffondere un progetto che si chiama
google village extraction side un kit di
50 macchine agricole e industriali per
la quale chiunque da qualunque parte del
mondo con una semplice possibilità di
accedere a internet può scaricare i
progetti di queste macchine che vanno da
un trattore a un forno per il pane a una
macchina per far circuiti elettrici a
una macchina per fare mattone in terra
cruda per costruirsi le case può
scaricarlo mettersi nel suo giardino nel
suo caso costruirselo e sono pensati con
criteri di modularità
efficienza semplicità non hanno avuto le
scienze programmate intrinseca bonino
non sono programmati per rompersi ma per
essere riparabili per essere prodotti
localmente quindi utilizzare gli
strumenti della tecnologia digitali e
delle community per rilocalizzare la
produzione
diffondibile sia nei mondi e nella parte
demoni che di sviluppo ma anche nel
primo mondo qui da noi per riportare a
noi quello che c'è stato un po lì è nato
che sapere come si fanno le cose non
essere più schiavi del consumismo ma
diventeranno gli stessi produttori
i famosi maker è l'obiettivo principale
di questo movimento però non è dire
eccoti il trattore vai a dare ha
coltivato il tuo campo è qualcosa di più
è creare un nuovo paradigma economico la
open source economy
l'open source economy è un processo per
la quale le persone i produttori
costruttori gli inventori o
semplicemente qualcuno che ha voglia di
condividere
mettete su una piattaforma stile wiki
page informazioni economicamente
rilevanti e la community in rete
le comunica le fa crescere non sono più
qualcosa di semplicemente meccanico
stelle non è un trattore non è una board
come arduino una stampante a3 di
comandare è un oggetto vivo perché le
persone lo fanno crescere lo condividono
lo riproducono e tutti possono
beneficiare di questa conoscenza di
questo know how diffuso
in italia per tutelare questo progetto
per diffonderlo abbiamo creato
un'associazione ormai un anno fa si
chiama isis iniziative per lo sviluppo
ecologico economico e sociale è il
nostro obiettivo è quello di diffondere
questa cosa e dico va bene proviamoci ci
siamo buttati ma come facciamo a
dimostrare che questa cosa funziona
mi sembra troppo etereo semplicemente
parlare di innovazione di noi modelli di
economia di un'agricoltura in una
manifattura sostenibile localizzata con
l'open source a
costruiamone un bambino fatto aveva
provato a costruire una macchina per
fare mentalmente racchiuda questa qui è
la foto è quello sono mattone di risulta
della produzione è però come tutti i
sogni
adesso arriva la realtà a cagli e ti
prendi una bella sberla perché incontri
la burocrazia
e ti devi arrangiare con quello che ti
dà la natura e gli strumenti del tuo
paese e noi abbiamo trovato il cie che
ci ha creato non pochi problemi perché
dice non stiamo parlando di una
stampante a3 di eventi per venti da
mettere sul tavolo in camera e giocare
stiamo parlando di una macchina di 600
kg che pressa a 120 tonnellate argilla e
paglia un trattore o un'automobile
quindi ci sono un sacco di normative di
cose da mettere in conto il nostro
contesto è assolutamente diverso da
quello americano dove è nato il
movimento loro possono fare qualunque
cosa nessuno gli dice niente
se ti fai male sono affari tuoi invece
qui da noi no noi abbiamo un'altra
cultura
però se me perché ha un bel sogno quindi
ritorniamo di nuovo in fase onirica che
non possiamo risolvere questo problema
siamo detti
boe potrebbe essere che magari possiamo
fare un'impresa a vedere come come hanno
fatto in unica come hanno risolto questo
problema loro del costruire le cose non
era un semplice giardino un garage e
allora abbiamo preso spunto veneto
perché non creare una nuova impresa in
italia
sul modello americano di open source
ecology però contestualizzata sulle
nostre necessità
abbiamo preso spunto dal quartier
generale di open source ecology factory
farm e ci siamo detti ok proviamoci una
nuova impresa di stampo cooperativistico
collaborativo legata sia
al mondo virtuale alla community per la
ricerca lo sviluppo la condivisione di
contenuti quindi l'applicazione dei
principi dell'open source economy ma
anche al mondo reale quindi la
concretezza del fare riprenderci in mano
il know how la possibilità di essere
autonomi
collegarci di nuovo al mondo tramite la
diffusione via internet
noi siamo un gruppo di persone
assolutamente
arrabattate a caso nate per errore su
una pagina facebook e il 2 di gennaio
del 2012 e che da lì e poi si sono
diffusi si sono conosciuti siamo un po
ovunque dalla puglia la campania
piemonte
veneto
se l'età di tutti quante le più
disparate esperienze di vita e formative
abbiamo una cosa in comune
noi vogliamo cambiare il mondo open
source technology
grazie